In order to get a better sense of how good this test is.
We not only have to take into account.
The results that were correct?
But also the results that were incorrect.
So we have true positives and true negatives.
Athletes who were genuinely not doping and athletes
who are genuinely topping but what about those
who were misclassified?
What about those who were accused of doping when they
were not and what about those who were in fact opening but
the evaded test?
If we put all of these numbers together, we'll
get a different picture. And once again, this is how we
calculate probability.
We have all of our possible outcomes.
In this case all of the positive tests.
And then the actual correct positive tests.
Now for this particular example, we're only going
to focus on the positive test because that's what the question is about.
Now, let me pull up that.
Figure just so we have it in front
of us here. And this is for later. Let me just hide this
for now.
so
19 tested positive
and they are actually doping.
However, 49 other athletes tested
positive when they were actually innocent.
So what we do is we put
the true positives and the denominator
and the false positives as well.
The correct number of doping athletes plus the incorrect
number of dolphin path athletes.
She gives us 68.
So 19 we're correctly tested positive, but
49 were not anyway, we calculate this.
It will evaluate this expression.
In decimal format we get 0.28 which is equal to
28%
So all things considered only 28% of
athletes who are actually guilty.
Are going to test positive.
Which means 72%
so here we put the
false positive in the numerator
49 over 19 plus 49
72% are going
to falsely be accused of doping.
So when we initially looked at this problem.
We thought that yeah, the test is 95% accurate.
So
95% of the athletes will be
correctly
testing positive
95 will be correctly testing negative.
But then we we did not we did not first. We may
have not first considered a 5%
Who would test positive and other 5% who test negative?
incorrectly
So when we have 980 athletes.
If 5% of those falsely test
positive that's going to change.
Let's go to change that's going to say different things about the
test.
And that's what we see here. 72% are going
to falsely be accused.
of testing positive of being guilty when
they are not
Now this is a this is
not exactly Bayesian.
Not yet.
but
the Bayesian theorem allows us to
account for all of this information
in that formula that we looked at earlier.
So we do not neglect.
critical information